welcome to this video don't cry Peter
masses is chilly right let's do the
Trump I played some Trump games and had
a fairly good score with that oh this is
this is a crazy line that I don't know
if I've is also also move that's not
that's not that great mm and I don't
really know I know this kind of kind of
line really okay yeah the long diagonal
is is some is something hmm still let's
see I mean
this kind of move must have some some
drawback yeah maybe I can exploit this
this kind of situation here a tick is 6
and 4 96 cos sp2 quality checking so I'm
going to simply wow ok I'm going to
close the long diagonal is what I wanted
to say e takes leaves me a little bit a
little bit puzzled don't really
understand the whole thing here just
what happens here and these six just
gone there you weird
queen bee 744 resignation I think
everything hangs well that was a weird
game black resigned mean what the heck
one happened here okay oh this is this a
certainty all right till here I mean I
don't even like my position that much
giving up the two bishops it's never
what I really love to do if I don't see
a clear compensation but ok hear my idea
with Knight c3 was to go night to be
five but what g5 is is is poo I don't
know it is it is not completely crazy
this idea and the Trump off scared it
happens we need you played that and put
it on the board it happens sometimes
that you want to go here and use this
long diagonal and you want to play g5 to
control air force oh that poor chair for
it's not possible this g five movies
designed to allow them to emphasize them
my why am i not able to get rid of the
arrows I would like to know why I cannot
get rid of the arrows this is crazy yeah
and it is designed to take why am I not
sorry I'm really a really a bit confused
normally with this with this clicks I
should get rid of the damn arrows and it
doesn't work instead it puts up some
other menu I don't know yeah and any in
any case um he wants to take use of her
long diagonal but here he's really am in
deep trouble immediately a cop wants to
go Knight f3 simply wear this this can't
be bad really oh oh oh I overlooked
something hmm interesting yeah I can
take me to this I didn't really think
about that much you can take care
because I do this check I'm in deep
trouble I have to go here and then be 6
is killing me
wow wow this be 70 yeah he I'm
devastated how okay it can take so what
am i doing after that c3 maybe a this
kind of move intending to trap the Queen
with Bishop c4 would be one now why does
even white ass better yeah the computer
computer gifts a big point is that if he
do does that now I have this move check
then I really win the rookie I'm so okay
it was okay for me but I didn't really
understand the whole implications 9 a-6
now see three looks good yeah and now i
don't know maybe we should be seven
after oh lordy six but taking a taking
is really really weird i mean he's just
well he's inviting my queen right into
the heart of his position and this is a
great place for it maybe you should play
Queen e6 now trying to trade queens this
looks really strange I mean the six is
basically gone now and after that he
loses really everything yeah kind of a
kind of a weird game this this line of
the Trump is interesting here with the
c5 the main point is led after a 5 which
looks kind of normal this age 60 of
course involved this year's is quite
good for black it seems and if I go all
the way back he well he doesn't want to
go here and give me tempe but like go
see a funny funny place for the night
the idea is that if a night comes to f3
you might be able to use this to
actually fire here undermining my
central control it's an interesting line
okay well thanks for watching